In packet switching, the information for forwarding traffic
is contained in the destination address of every
datagram or packet. Similar to how you would
write a letter and specify the destination to where
you want the letter sent, and that letter
might wend its way through multiple intermediate post
offices en-route to the recipient, packet switching works
much the same way. There is no state established
ahead of time. And there are very few
assumptions made about the level of service that the
network provides. This assumption about the level of service
that the network provides, is sometimes called best effort.
So how does packet switching enable sharing. Just as
if you were sending a letter. Many senders can
send over the same network at the same time,
effectively sharing the resources in the network. A similar
phenomenon occurs in packet switching when multiple
senders send network traffic or packets over the
same set of shared network links. Now this
is in contrast to the phone network. Where
if you were to make a phone call, the resources for the path between you and
the recipient are dedicated and are allocated until
the phone call ends. The mode of switching
that the conventional phone network uses is
called circuit switching. Where a signalling protocol
sets up the entire path out-of-band. So
this notion of packet switching and statistical multiplexing
allowing multiple users to share a resource
at the same time was really revolutionary.
And it is one of the underlying
design principles of the internet that has persisted.
Now, an advantage of statistical multiplexing
of the links and the network, means
that the sender never gets a busy
signal. The drawbacks include things like variable
delay and the potential for lost or
dropped packets. In contrast, circuit switching provides
resource control, better accounting and reservation of
resources and the ability to pin paths
between a sender and receiver. Packet switching provides the
ability to share resources and potentially better resilience properties.